[Music]
lift it higher
higher
my baby's night has to be perfect and
it's not perfect and people are going to
be coming the flowers
[Music]
thank you oh it's
a nothing sisterly advice if you weren't
always trying too hard you wouldn't be
in the way actually isa this is called
helping and i'm not in the way you are
many years ago
this scandal blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
magic
la casita
[Music]
[Music]
i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in his family
you just healed my hand with an adepa
con queso
casita
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait how do i save the magic
[Music]
the fate of the family it's gonna come
down to you i can't do this let me help
you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
[Music]
but at least i'll have a friend nope he
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
you